et didier guillaume le président du
groupe socialiste au sénat est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir soi et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez vous
donc de public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse et dailymotion
la crise de l'élevage s'invite au coeur
de l'été nous l'évoquerons dans un
instant avec perrine tarneaud alors que
françois hollande annonce un plan
d'urgence et que stéphane le foll
finalement s'est rendu sans attendre en
normandie mais des réformes en
profondeur s'impose pour sortir les
éleveurs on les entend d'une situation
devenue intenable un dossier que vous
connaissez bien didier guillaume
d'ailleurs votre nom avait circulé un
pour le ministère de l'agriculture
l'homonymie avec lycéens ministre oui on
parlera également de 2017 au cours de
cette émission comment françois hollande
road son discours de près candidat
malgré une impopularité record et même
structure elle nous en parlerons à la
fin de l'émission avec katell prigent
alors que vous partagez au moins un
trait de caractère avec le chef de
l'état c'est à dire l'optimisme
ah oui puisque vous vous dites
optimistes sur la réussite du
quinquennat je le pense je le pense
parce que bien sûr on veut tout le temps
aller vite on se dit que le quinquennat
aujourd'hui il est fini on voudrait
projeter les élections présidentielles
de 2017
aujourd'hui en juillet 2015 mais un
quinquennat est dure cinq ans et
aujourd'hui les premières réformes ont
été mises en place jamais jamais un
président n'a autant réformes et que
celui ci c'est peut-être d'ailleurs un
peu ça le problème parce que les
français ont du mal à suivre
jamais autant mesures de fond était
prise dans une crise sans précédent la
guerre le terrorisme
la situation en europe et où il faut
repenser les fondamentaux de nos
équilibres budgétaires
il faut une gestion rigoureuse la dette
a filé des déficits en fils et dernier
quinquennat on peut nous dire que
c'était à cause de la crise 2008 à la
crise elle est toujours là et l'action
du chef de l'état en france est
clairement oui le un chef dont on en
parlera tout à l'heure vous nous dire
est que donc françois hollande plus que
jamais et le candidat qui s'impose et
qui est le candidat naturel de la gauche
en 2010 cet été guillaume ou non comme
un tout à l'heure évidemment été l'autre
qualité s'impose à la tête des sénateurs
ps dans un sénat de droite qui impose
ses choix et sa vision aux quarts
le bourg de la politique suivie par
l'exécutif mais le crh moldaves ont rêvé
le sénat travaille et travaille pas trop
mal et l'opposition sénatoriale arrive à
se faire entendre
nous arrivons avant c'est d'ailleurs le
consensus que nous avons obtenus sur la
réforme territoriale en territoriaux
c'est le seul c'est déjà bien ça montre
que nous pouvons travailler avec la
majorité sénatoriale et je veux saluer
le président larcher d'avoir une courage
d'avancer dans cette direction
d'après ce que j'ai pu comprendre compte
l'avis du président du parti du parti du
principal parti d'opposition pourquoi
vous parlez de nicolas sarkozy le jour
ce qu'il y avait des choses qui vont
dans le bon sens nous y reviendront
peut-être pour l'aviculture tout à
l'heure alors tout le monde doit se dire
avance on bosse avec vous salue et donc
ce soir l'esprit de dialogue déjà livrés
absolument il a il a été c'est un
président qui écoute qui a une liberté
de ton et qui est un président qui veut
faire vivre cette institution et je veux
saluer vous allez peut-être encore le
salut est plus avant puisque vous aimez
l'opposé à nicolas sarkozy il a dit que
toutes les réformes ne serait pas
abrogée ça aussi c'était une bonne chose
c'est ça sort de sa bouche c'est évident
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas candidat à
l'élection présidentielle il est
candidat pour prendre sa revanche face à
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy ne
comprend pas qu'un autre tu lui plus
être président donc il abroge c'est
monsieur abrogatoire il veut tout
abrogée et in fine et il n'abroge sera
rien parce que j'espère que le peuple
l'empêchera de dette réduite alors
jamais on n'a autant réforme et
l'affirmation il pourra faire bondir et
certains dédié guillaume est ce que
c'est la fin a désormais des réformes
avec le temps qui va si vite vous l'avez
rappelé le quinquennat il reste deux ans
mais non non mais si on nous a annoncé
le temps de la redistribution et il faut
continuer à réformer réformer sans cesse
aller on est un peu de tours de france
c'est comme le vélo 1
si on arrête de pédaler on se casse la
figure
si le gouvernement arrête de réformer il
se cassera la figure il n'y aura pas de
possibilité d'une nouvelle élection de
françois hollande en 2017
de nombreuses réformes ont été faites
par rapport à l'an ii du futur la wii
mais je peux vous par des futures par
exemple quand personnel d'activité qui
va être mise en place très important une
mesure sociale évidente
la loi biodiversité avec notamment la
préparation de la coupe 21 ce que nous
voulons mettre en place nous c'est la
social écologie c'est à dire que
l'écologie ne peut pas être présentée
uniquement par un parti aujourd'hui
l'enjeu planétaire veut que chaque à ce
souci d'écologie et le président de la
république était encore ce matin au
sommet des consciences avec beaucoup de
responsables politiques sous l'animation
de nicolas hulot il est indispensable
que cette prise de conscience
environnementale
elle serait fait à grande échelle
quelles sont les réformes pour vraiment
changer la vie quotidienne des français
et notamment résorber le chômage dans
notre pays et que la loi macron c'est
pas une grande réforme
ces images on parle des réformes à venir
elle est à venir celle-là michel
grossiord elle vient d'être votée il ya
quelques accords sont avant l'agression
est un venin il faut la mettre en place
quand on est là on la route déjà
macron 2 oui mais ça car si on me
demandait mon avis ben je demandai je
vais vous répondre je préférerais que de
l'eau macro 1 soit bien appliquée avant
qu'on essaye d'en aborder une autre
parce que je veux que nous réformions ne
réforme pas coude annonce en réformes à
coude objectifs politiques et les
objectifs politiques quels sont ils
c'est la réduction de la dette et des
déficits c'est la création d'emplois
c'est booster l'économie afin que
l'économie française fonctionne mieux et
c'est rendre le quotidien de nos
concitoyens
sa seule philosophie générale à sa
démission mais je vous adresser
directement à françois hollande que que
vous défendez avec tout ça vous d'accord
mais vous répondait à françois hollande
qui a annoncé mais non pas du tout vous
êtes dans les commentaires il a dit il
peut y avoir des mesures bateau monde a
compris cela en avoir discuté peut-être
mais nous verrons bien ce qui se passera
moi ce que je veux c'est réussir
l'instant présent l'instant présent
c'est en septembre 9 millions de foyers
fiscaux vont voir leurs impôts baisser
c'est la première plus grandes baisses
fiscales de la vème république mais
ferait évidemment pas les au service
excessive de les routes les années
passées je suis de droite gauche
confondues oui mais je sors je suis
d'accord pour que l'emportent de ces
hausses
oui 18
19 milliards de hausse sous le
quinquennat sarkozy 19 20 milliards vous
reconnaissez que ça n'a pas été une
bonne option une bonne fée laissez moi
finir mais la grande différence entre
ces deux quinquennats
bien sûr qui a trop d'impôts en france
enfin on veut des services la grande
différence entre ces deux quinquennats
seksu nicolas sarkozy des impôts ont
augmenté le nombre de fonctionnaires a
baissé moins de pauses dans la justice -
deux policiers - deux gendarmes moins
une personne dans le renseignement
moins d'enseignants de fermetures de
classes c'est une réalité à keanu
lorsque nous avons augmenté les impôts
par exemple nous sommes revenus sur la
fameuse loi tepa
nous sommes revenus sur le bouclier
fiscal nous avons augmenté l'impôt de
solidarité sur la sur la fortune nous
avons imposé le capital au même niveau
qu ils travaillent ah oui c était d
aider des mesures pas d'autocritique
bien sûr je pense que nous avons trop
augmenter les impôts mais juste que je
vais vous dire ici c'est lorsque l'on
alors vous allez me dire parlez pas du
bilan c'est du passé
enfin lorsque l'on se retrouve en 2012
avec une augmentation de la dette de 600
milliards d'euros en un quinquennat vous
rendez compte que ces 600 milliards
d'euros ben il faut bien à essayer
d'ajuster quand même alors donc vous
l'avez rappelé il ya un instant didier
guillaume des compromis peuvent survenir
au sénat et comme par miracle sur la
réforme territoriale nord l'irak je
crois que c'est par conviction sauver
les sénateurs sont des femmes et des
hommes de terrain
ils sont aperçus que nous pouvions
réformer de façon concrète
l'administration territoriale ce qui
s'est passé quand même il ya deux ans on
ne disait jamais nous n'arriverons nous
n'arriverions à diminuer le nombre de
régions là doivent avoir des élections
régionales peut-être un poil en outre à
l'heure avec treize régions au lieu de
22 jamais nous n'arriverions à clarifier
les compétences s'est fait dans la loi
notre n'envoyer que c'est difficile
nous réformons c'est difficile tous les
conservatismes de droite comme de gauche
se rassemble pour dire non c'est trop il
n'empêche qu'une veyron avancer et pour
la fin du quinquennat
moi je pense que nous avons besoin de
stabilité de continuité et d'efficacité
nous avons besoin de stabilité parce
qu'on ne change pas au milieu du gué une
stratégie on ne change pas la tactique
de l'équipe il faut avancer
même si nous avons eu des élections
difficiles et qui honore les autres
regardez
ici les régionales nous en prendrons
peut-être tout à l'heure mais bien sûr
un peu de voir peut-être même dramatique
pour la au dramatique le têt
nous verrons bien mais nous devons
avancer et nous devons contribuer à
présent mais perdu leurs avoirs avant
j'ai commencé les trafics bon suis
sportif à revendre
il faut de la continuité aussi la
graphique a été ces mesures sont
efficaces je voulais beau aborder un
instant le débat parlementaire parce que
il prend des allures de ping pong
vous l'avez noté évidemment entre le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale qui a le
dernier mot avec une grosse différence
quand même le ping pong est un jeu
rapide mais là ça freine tout vous lirez
vous le déplorez oui je partage ce que
vous dite je partage ce point je pense
que nous légiférons trop lentement
beaucoup trop lentement à l'heure de
l'instantanéité des faits c'est rare
d'entendre un parlementaire les
dirigeants
c'est le discours de l'exécutif
particulièrement en soi alors je vais
vous le dire qu'ils ont mais j'ai été
rapporteur de la loi agricole
oui quand on met un an et demi pour
faire voter une loi quand sur le mariage
pour tous ont mis un nom sur la loi
macron mais plus d'un an
franchement est la faute à qui mais
c'est la faute à tout le monde et
surtout à nos institutions c'est pour ça
que je j'aurai l'occasion de faire des
propositions d'ici la fin de l'année de
réformes institutionnelles exemple pour
essayer de plus belle à baliser la fin
de l'année comme essaie de les pistes de
fluidifier les pistes c'est peut-être
que on n'est pas 3 lecture par assemblée
lorsqu'il ya un texte franchement on
passe une première fois puis on passe
une deuxième fois il a saigné barbe ça
n'en finit pas alors il s'agit pas de
réduire le débat parlementaire
mais la première lecture doit être celle
où tout tout est sur la table
les amendements où on fait de la
confrontation politique en donne des
orientations différentes s'il le faut et
puis après il faut aller plus fort va
pas continuer à passer mais votre
gouvernement s'y arrête de vous proposer
des textes avec des centaines d'articles
où il est licite et de la loi mâcon il
ya un instant franchement oui mais nous
nous savons bien sûr que le gouvernement
est là cette offre et rhodia aussi les
trente ans derrière le bruit l'argument
a tort de vouloir nous faire trop la
corée avec des textes trop important
mais regardez ce qui se passe c'est que
le parlement en assembler comme le sénat
rajoute 50 60 cents 200 articles là vous
voulez limiter ça aussi non pas du tout
non on peut pas dire il peut pas y avoir
plus de temps article moi je souhaite
qu'il y
tous les lois et non de lecture loi
moins bavarde des lois plus courte et
plus forte et des lois qui soit augmenté
plus rapidement en attendre à
l'aventurier légiste c'est quand ils
voient l'annonçons conseil des ministres
d'une proposition de loi ou d'une loi et
d'un projet de loi pardon mais ça ne
crois que ça va c'est le gouvernement il
joue de l'effet d'annoncé ne savez ça
ils jouent non c'est le nom à lui arrive
ce sont les institutions
michel grossiord et on doit annoncer en
conseil des ministres le projet de loi
il est annoncé et après la loi est
promulguée deux ans après ce n'est plus
possible en scène
alors nous allons maintenant donc évoqué
la fronde des éleveurs mobilisés en
normandie notamment contre une crise
sans précédent qui menace nous dit-on
officiellement une exploitation sur dix
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et les
secteurs du lait de la vache de la
viande bovine et du port sont frappées
de deux points fait dans l'urne de
pointe de plein fouet depuis depuis des
mois maintenant mais dans l'urgence
alors que les actions se sont donc
multipliées un plan sera présenté ce
mercredi en conseil des ministres et
donc stéphane le foll a précipité son
déplacement nathalie gloire trop de
l'agriculture a changé d'avis
aujourd'hui il décide de se rendre à
caen pour apaiser des tensions
il me semble logique à la fois par
respect pour les éleveurs du calvados et
de la normandie que je connais je suis
déjà venu et en même temps parce que
maintenant on a un certain nombre de
dispositions de répondre à la demande
qui avait été faite il ya quelques jours
de venir rencontrer les éleveurs sa
venue c'était l'une des conditions
imposées par les éleveurs pour la levée
du blocage des routes
il a enfin cédé sa montre que les
actions qu'on a menée
ici au mont saint-michel paye et aide
ceux qui ont et qu'à l'initiative les
deux camps maintenant aujourd'hui
attendons de voir ce qu'il va proposer
mais nous croyons pas au miracle
on est là pour un changement profond de
l'agriculture on est rendu au bout à
l'obsolescence totale de notre modèle
donc aujourd'hui il faut que les choses
changent
face à cette situation le rythme s'est
accéléré toute la journée
ce matin c'est françois hollande qui
reprend la main et monte au créneau
il donne le ton de la journée demain le
conseil des ministres prendra des
décisions
j'ai demandé qu'au delà de la question
de la distribution des prix il puisse y
avoir un plan d'urgence pour les
éleveurs français et pour les confitures
de lèvres ce sera donc annoncer demain
pas question que la situation s'envenime
davantage une réunion a donc été
organisée au pied levé ce matin matignon
sur des filières d'élevage
le ministre parle d'une dizaine de
propositions contenues dans son plan
d'urgence et évoque notamment la piste
de l'allègement de l'endettement des
éleveurs en attendant le plan d'urgence
qui sera dévoilé demain à la sortie du
conseil des ministres
le médiateur doit remettre son rapport
ce soir à stéphane le foll voilà donc
toutes les questions agricoles que vous
connaissez bien je le disais tout à
l'heure un didier guillaume sans
homonymie possible avec un site ministre
de l'agriculture les questions de
perrine tarneaud cancer enfin michel
bonsoir didier déjà sur la visite de
stéphane le foll sur le terrain
aujourd'hui pourquoi il a tant tardé à
venir à la rencontre des éleveurs qu'il
appelait depuis ce week-end à venir il
s'agit pas d' accélérer de tarder à ne
pas tarder à les voir les agriculteurs
sans que le dossier n'est pas stabilisé
et sans avoir quelque chose à leur dire
jordi bas il est venu il n'a rien
annoncé donc nous continuons il fallait
prendre le temps
est ce que le temps s'était situation
inconnue on connaît la situation déjà
sur belleu le plan le lan oui mais le
plan va être présenté demain matin en
conseil des ministres c'est pas le
ministre de l'agriculture qui allait le
faire ce week-end tout seul je voudrais
aller qui s'est précipité sur or signée
lei de les effets chez vous le permettez
si vous le permettez la situation est
trop grave pour parler de coup de
sifflet ou de je ne sais trop quoi
stéphane le foll est un grand ministre
de l'agriculture il connaît très bien
son dossier il va sur le terrain
il a alerté les éleveurs au sénat il ya
très longtemps
il a mis en place les cellules de crise
depuis février il a réuni le 17 juin
cette fameuse réunion où des choses
endettés
ah non c'est vrai mais l'accord du 17
juin qui n'est pas appliquée c'est ça
qui postulait sur le terrain et ce qui
pose aussi problème c'est son silence ce
week-end d'ailleurs l'opposition de
droite s'est engouffrée dans ce silence
bel air par exemple ils dénoncent le
mépris de stéphane le foll a mais je
vais vous dire moi
bruno le maire agite les stéphane le
foll agit c'est ça la grande différence
quand on a été ministre de l'agriculture
quatre ans quand on a soutenu la lm que
la loi de modernisation de l'économie
qui est ou dérégulé quand on a été
d'accord pour la fin des quotas laitiers
et quand on prône le libéralisme
économique
alors on devrait se taire ou avoir la
décence de ne pas faire de la
récupération politique parce que je vais
vous dire moi
perrine tarneaud ce que je pense c'est
que la récupération politique à des fins
régional par les présidents de
conseiller les candidats ou pour la
présidence de conseils régionaux n'est
pas acceptable
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de fautes de la droite et de
l'europe libérale qui a voulu
libéraliser l'économie l'agriculture la
lme c'est monsieur sarkozy monsieur
fillion années monsieur et monsieur le
maire et la fin des quotas laitiers
c'est la droite je suis désolé
maintenant il ya trois crises et ces
trois crises il faut les voir en une
seule fois et la crise agricole la crise
industrielle et la crise sociétale si on
donnait une minute je veux bien aller
sans la crise agricole
elle est très importantes à régler les
agriculteurs les éleveurs sont dans une
situation catastrophique
on ne peut pas les laisser crever dans
leur coin sans les aider il faut que
mara 13 il faut qu'ils comprennent que
ce gouvernement ce ministre du chef de
l'état le premier ministre sont là pour
les aider
moi je ne dirai jamais la culture est
finie notre modèle agricole n'est pas
finie notre modèle agricole il a de
l'avenir et les éleveurs il faut les
aider tout simplement avec des prix chez
vous dire ce que je pense là dessus mais
c'est pas moi qui fixe les prix
attendez attendez vous achetez une
voiture achetée une table vous acheter
une baguette de paris
vous négociez pas les prix quelle
profession dans notre pays vend en
dessous du prix de revient
bah c'est scandaleux c'est ce qu'on a
fait à qui donc jour les distributeurs
je vais vous dire je vais vous dire
l'accord du 17 juin il doit être
en application il faut que les
industriels mais alors comment les
transformateurs il voyait parce que
visiblement il n'est pas exactement mais
c'est là toute la question mais c'est là
toute la question
alors je voudrais préciser ce que c'est
que cet accord du 17 juin une
augmentation progressive du bois à l'ail
et au kilo en gros entre 20 centimes
toutes les fois leur voilà en gros pour
le port emmené à 2 centimes de ce qui
était fixé pour l'est pour le 17 juin
donc ça va à peu près on est beaucoup
plus loin sur les bovins mais nous avons
deux problèmes disons le faux faut tout
mettre sur la table un l'embargo russe
dont je pense qu'il faut que nous en
parlions parce que l'embargo russe pose
là bruno le maire il faut qu'ils
agissent mais je vais je vais voir il
faut que les leçons de boulot le maire
ça suffit et puis il ya hollande a parlé
avec sursis à hollande d'en parler avec
les acteurs européens et plus la grèce
la grèce
une grande majorité des jeunes bovins
sont exportés en dresse est aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que nous qu'est ce que nous
disent les transformateurs disent mes
troupes
on veut être payé et on sait pas si la
grèce sera solvable une des raisons pour
laquelle on a bien fait de pas là
sortiront donc il ya ce problème là à
créer moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
je veux dire aux agriculteurs
c'est que nous les aimons c'est que nous
voulons qu'ils s'en sortent
nous allons tout faire pour qu'il s'en
sorte d'ange à respecter l'accord et en
mettant les transformateurs et les
industriels devant leurs responsabilités
si les grandes surfaces achètent plus
cher les bovins ou les ports et si les
agriculteurs se font toujours serré la
gorge au risque d'être étouffée
ça veut dire que milieu et des circuits
commerciaux qui dysfonctionne et on ne
peut pas l'accepter
ça c'est là qu'ils avaient commis à la
crise industrielle alors juste pour
finir sur la crise agricole dans les
solutions franco-françaises est-ce qu'il
faut aussi prendre en charge une partie
de la dette des éleveurs un milliard de
dettes cumulées selon la fnsea demande
d'excusés
un que je respecte profondément c'est
pas ça le sujet du n'importe quoi
non pas du tout pas du tout enfin un
milliard pourquoi pas 2 pourquoi pas 5
je pense qu'il faut que vision des
choses simples il n'y aura pas un jeune
éleveur en dépôt de bilan zéro tout
jeune et bien sûr tout jeune qui est
endetté et qui a dépensé de l'argent qui
a emprunté pour son élevage
alors celui ci nous on est des priorités
a aucun jeune ne doit être laissé de
côté et l'objectif c'est d'éviter les
dépôts de bilan
il faudra prendre des mesures qui
coûteront cher mais je ne peux pas dire
autour de cette table avec vous quand
bien s'est il ya des moments forts
niveaux des bonnets déjà des énergies en
urgence rien je vous donne vous
m'interrogez je vous donne ma position
je ne veux pas la position de stéphane
le foll je pense qu'il faut aider les
agriculteurs
au niveau fiscal vote et puis il faut
interpeller les banques et notamment la
banque des agriculteurs qui n'a pas
voulu jouer le jeu et il faut c'est ce
qu'a fait stéphane deux fois de la
semaine dernière en voyant credit
agricole en voyant d'autres banques en
faisant maintenant il faut que vous
aidiez les éleveurs qui sont endettés
faut reporter des échances faut tout
faire pour s'en sortir
ça s'est il faut régler il faut aussi
peut-être des mesures de simplification
parce qu'il est une avance qui a été
consenti sur la pac mais les formulaires
sont trop compliqué il faut le ministre
le ministre a pris des positions pour
aller plus loin donc il ya la crise
industrielle
c'est pour ça que l'entrée en lice dans
le débat des manuels macron ce matin et
est indispensable parce que quand nous
parlons des industriels
c'est pat sont pas des entreprises
agricoles et il faut travailler au
niveau de l'économie
et puis évidemment au niveau européen il
faut que ali c'est ce qu'a fait stéphane
le foll depuis des mois et des mois en
travaillant avec dassier en solo ce
d'abord puis maintenant avec le nouveau
commissaire européen
phil hogan en disant il faut tu avances
et c'est le travail qui est fait avancer
et faut changer quoi il faut arriver à
faire de la régulation
il faut que l'europe non mais je vous
dire très clairement il faut que
l'europe acceptent de mettre de l'argent
sur la table pour faire du déstockage
on n'a pas le choix autrement on n'a pas
le choix
moi je veux pas que les éleveurs qui
crève donc il faut savoir gérer l'argent
poteev encore
le président du sénat a raison de saisir
le président de la commission européenne
et bien c'est ce que fait le chef de
l'état le premier ministre et le
ministre de l'agriculture mois si tout
le monde droite comme gauche se disait
nous allons nous en sortir nous allons
tous interpellés tous tirer dans la même
direction
ça ne me pose aucun problème à ce qu'un
problème qu'il faudrait que le
gouvernement français demande une
réunion 1 des mises là des laïcs mais il
y en a une lui il ya une à une il ya pas
très longtemps et c'est là une réunion
des ministres européens
simplement la fin des quotas laitiers
n'a pas été interprété de la maison ne
remédie à l'époque on est même prêt à
affronter la complimente marché en était
sa marge est due par ce qui s'est passé
en chine
mais lui-même était confiant non non non
stéphane le foll a voté green dernier
les fans le foll étaient députés
européens il a voté contre la fin des
quotas
stéphane de foi de culture il a dit
attention attention mais à les nouveaux
marchés et oui notamment la chine mais
ils n'obtiennent monde s'est précipité
sur la chine
aujourd'hui la chine achète moins de
lait et il ya un vrai problème puis si
je peux me permettre la troisième grief
sociétal le patriotisme le patriotisme
français une belle valeur patriotisme et
moi j'appelle tous mes concitoyens
toutes les françaises et des français
comme on l'a acheté français à manger
française asensi une solution de long
terme dans les studios de court terme et
de long terme si systématiquement
lorsqu'on achète cet été des côtes des
merguez et chipotons pas quoi pour faire
des pour faire des barbecues
si on va acheter une côte de veau une
côte de boeuf une côte de porc si on
achète des fruits pourquoi ne pas
acheter français
enfin c'est indispensable et le label
viande de france mais les éleveurs
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas un
étiquetage suffisamment il est mise en
place la défense en attaque a été lancée
au dernier salon de l'agriculture par le
ministre la fnsea et les filières
d'élevage
ça a été lancé ça va être à mon avis
remis un peu au goût du jour la viande
de france c'est absolument qu'ils tuent
près tous d'accord pour acheter pour
manger français méritent bien sûr avec
vous alors illégaux mais oui mais
regardez par exemple je vois madame
emmanuelle cosse qu'est la secrétaire
nationale d'europe ecologie-les verts
dit elle on produit de la viande en fait
que personne ne veut qu'on achète plus
et qu'on réserve à l'exportation voilà
ce qu'elle dit
elle m'en voulez me faire dire des
choses aujourd'hui moi je regrette
vraiment la dépêche d'emmanuel coste je
ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne
position pour rappeler que la vérité
soit une bonne position pour recopier de
gilet vert de montrer du doigt les
agriculteurs de montrer du doigt ceux
qui entretiennent le paysage ac est très
discret du doigt ceux qui sont de vrais
écologistes parce que quand le veuille
ou non ça évoluer en 20 ans et
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs sont de
vrais écolos c'est eux qui entretiennent
les paysages les éleveurs sans les
éleveurs
il y aurait des friches partout dans nos
mangas mais là c'est la qualité de ce
qu'on mange et baise je regrette elle se
trompe oui qu'elle dénonce le modèle
productiviste et bien le modèle français
pour moi il n'est pas mort le modèle
agricole français il a de l'avenir
il faut faire des évolutions on voit
bien il y aurait pas cette crise si tout
si tout allait bien dans le meilleur des
mondes mais je crois que ce genre de
discours
ce genre de discours contribuer à ne pas
arranger la situation donc je regrette
qu emmanuel pallas énoncé ses propos et
je regrette les avions de la grille
comme modèle productiviste à bout de
souffle
on sait pas à bout de souffle et
j'appelle moi toutes les françaises et
français à manger de la bonne viande cet
été il ya de la très bonne viande de la
trés trés malgré tout pour servir est ce
que les agriculteurs français ne sont
pas obligés condamnés à se regrouper
dans des unités de production plus
importante
non je pense que notre modèle agricole
français il faut le maintenir pas le
maintenir pour le maintenir comme au
19ème siècle c'est pas ça le sujet moi
je suis opposé aux fermes des
millevaches et sagot duvauroux des 5000
ou des 10000 non mais moi je préfère un
éleveur avec 50 ou 100 vache qu'un
éleveur avec millevaches
voilà et donc ce modèle là il faut
peut-être moderniser les choses il faut
peut-être qu'il y ait des regroupements
faut peut-être que voilà ce travail-là
sur le long terme
il doit avoir lieu et les agriculteurs
et les filières d'élevage sont en train
de faire ce travail
mais aujourd'hui la difficulté dans
laquelle nous sommes elle est double
c'est qu'il faut répond une crise
conjoncturelle d'urgence sans ça il peut
y avoir des centaines d'éleveurs sur le
carreau donc il faut répondre des
mesures d'urgence et en même temps être
les problèmes de frein suffira pas donc
il faut continuer continuer continuer
sans cesse à travailler sur le fond pour
sauver notre modèle agricole pour nous
faire entendre au niveau
européens et pour faire en sorte que
cette agriculture puisse se développer
dans le cadre de la concurrence
internationale
réguler mais il faut la réguler et ça me
fait d'ailleurs toujours rire tout soit
les libéraux qui demande une économie
notamment au niveau européen il ya aussi
une directive qui pose problème c'est
celle sur les travailleurs détachés qui
explique que notamment les charges
sociales dans les entreprises agricoles
allemandes soient beaucoup moins élevé
problème c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement et le chef de l'état
entend annoncer qu'il fallait régler le
problème des travailleurs détachés
je pense que nous arrivons à le régler
mais je pense qu'il faut pas opposer les
allemands aux français oui bien sûr oui
mais ça le modèle agricole
d'accord mais enfin si on regarde très
objectivement les choses les problèmes
de l'élevage ou du lait enfin de
l'élevage en général soit pour la viande
ou pour le lait c'est pas parce qu'elle
est des des coûts de travailleurs
détachés plus bas en allemagne et je
crois qu'il ya pas que ça mais nous
avons gardé un élément oui moi je veux
une europe qui régule une europe qui
puisse redistribuées et surtout une
europe qui aident à traverser les
difficultés
voilà c'est ça l'europe que je veux et
le travail que mène le président de la
république auprès de monsieur juncker
je crois qu'il a vu d'ailleurs le
commissaire pierre moscovici
hier où il est aujourd'hui pendant ces 3
souvent maintenant mais souvent pour
travailler est ce que fait le mr la
culture avec le commissaire européen à
l'agriculture doit porter si la couleur
savez si je pouvais dire une phrase de
conclusion l'heure elle est très grave
très grave
il en va de l'avenir de notre modèle de
notre pays est ce que nous voulons
encore avoir des agriculteurs des
éleveurs des femmes et des hommes qui
travaillent 7 jours sur 7 pour faire des
produits de grande qualité en france où
est-ce que tout va être acheté à
l'extérieur de façon industrielle
ben moi je veux soutenir les
agriculteurs français et acheter des
produits de très grande qualité en
circuit court suppôts cible ou en
circuit lent mais de qualité la qualité
avant tout et les agriculteurs doivent
entendre mais je pense que le ministre a
dû leur dire cet après midi je ne sais
pas ce qui s'est dit dans cette table
ronde
et puis ce soir la réunion avec
l'ensemble de la file des filières et
les
les présidents nationaux et demain les
mesures on a surpris dans le bon sens
avec un risque de propagation en tous
les cas un tandem des actions je vais
aux carriers vous avez peur sinon je
note qu'en fait notamment la cani qu'on
fait de la politique apaisée on fait de
la politique jeunesse
il ya deux choses que je veux dire c'est
que la sécheresse pose de vrais
problèmes pour la nourriture des animaux
notamment pour la paille 1 on aura en
aura on aura un problème
et puis quand même je comprends la
désespérance je suis je pense que
certains éleveurs se distançant je n'ai
plus rien à perdre il faut penser aussi
que dans les petites surfaces ou dans
les moyennes surfaces on a des grandes
surfaces
il ya aussi des français qui travaillent
des français qui sont à temps partiel
qui sont à peine au smig et je pense
qu'il faut pas opposer des catégories
les unes aux autres
moi j'appelle au calme les
revendications sont anormales ils ont
des choses à dire se nourrissent des
éleveurs opposants mais j'ai vu les
images publiées division où il y avait
dans la gazet grande chaîne dénonce
méthodes bien sûr m'intimider aller les
fournisseurs
mais évidemment pris la lm avec les
marges arrières l'émargement c'est
totalement ça très bien merci beaucoup
perrine merci michel dernier remercie le
propre 3 et que katell prigent de l'
agence france presse qui nous rejoint
maintenant et qui avec qui nous allons
évoquer la situation politique du chef
de l'état et que l'on voit donc présent
sur tous les terrains en ce moment
surtout les foulures aux brochures il
n'était pas présent
s'il est là présent il est trop mais
s'il n'est pas vous dites mais une
manière pour mieux en tout les gars et
ça c'est sûr d'occuper l'espace
politique dans ce qui ressemble à une
pré-campagne pour 2010 est pourtant les
choses semblent mal engagées
vous allez pouvoir répondre mais d'abord
l'enquète de louis sybille 2017 c'est
bien l'horizon de françois hollande
reste une épine dans le pied est de
taille
l'emploi la courbe n'est toujours pas
inversée c'était pourtant le cheval de
bataille du président de quoi remettre
en cause sa légitimité de candidat
naturel
certains demandent déjà des primaires
une opinion partagée par 65% des
sympathisants de gauche
il faut qu'il serait légitime auprès du
peuple de gauche et je ne vois que les
primaires sinon le mécontentement
globale et s'exprimant avec son
président
elle est en tout cas s'il n'est pas
capable de gagner les primaires je vois
pas comment il peut imaginer gagner une
élection présidentielle pour ses fidèles
françois hollande est le seul candidat
possible certains sont très confiants
pour les deux prochaines années la
question ça pas de savoir si le chômage
va commencer à baisser ou pas il va
baisser la question réelle est de savoir
pour nous la gauche nous souhaitons en
2017 voir la droite revenir au pouvoir
et si nous ne souhaitons pas alors passé
un moment cette courbe du chômage va
baisser
il va falloir que nous tirions tous dans
le même sens et nous disons tous bien la
même chose
la seule chose qui à dire c'est que non
pas une politique sociale libérale c'est
que nous menons une politique qui
fonctionne et qui redresse le pays il
est là le message
sur le plan diplomatique françois
hollande a peaufiné sa posture de chef
international avec l'intervention
militaire au mali sa gestion des
attentats ou plus proche son engagement
pour maintenir la grèce dans l'europe
pas de quoi capitaliser des points au
niveau national il ya un seul élément
qui lui permettrait de regagner des
points c'est d'obtenir des résultats
significatifs c'est à dire massif et
durable dans le domaine de la lutte
contre le chômage
même si le président arrive à baisser le
chômage difficile de penser qu'il
inversera complètement la courbe depuis
son arrivée au pouvoir il y a six cent
mille chômeurs de plus mais pour ses
proches il ne peut pas changer de cap
le pire serait d'avoir une politique on
essuie glaces raid s'interroger
perpétuellement de se regarder le
nombril et se dire est ce qu'on fait
bien où est ce qu'on fait pas bien quand
on trace une perspective on s'y tient
vous savez quand vous charrues et un
champ vous passez pas votre temps à
partir à droite et à gauche vous prenez
au début vous avez jusqu'au bout on y
est problème un récent sondage montre
que même si le chômage baisse de façon
significative
75 % des français ne souhaitent pas que
le président de la république se
représente dans la capelle présent est
avec nous à des défis communs
alors là encore est ce que vous êtes
optimiste sur françois hollande candidat
malgré la question du chômage comme un
pic des ministres nous le disions tout à
l'heure en début d'émission il reste
deux ans d'élections présidentielles
auront lieu dimanche prochain
je me serais un peu moins optimiste p on
n'est pas là on est en train de fixer le
cadre pour préparer la fin du
quinquennat
avant de penser à l'élection
présidentielle il faut penser aux
français et moi je veux nous pensions
aux français c'est ce que fait françois
hollande c'est ce que fait manuel valls
et le gouvernement et les parlementaires
socialistes qui les soutiennent
c'est quoi les français ils veulent du
travail de la sécurité et un logement
mais c'est ce que nous essayons de
mettre en place avec les diverses lois
que nous avons voté depuis 2012
il reste deux ans utilisons ces deux ans
pour continuer à réformer
l'élection de 2017 va pas non plus se
préparer à la veille de semaine avant
elle commence déjà ça commence déjà
c'est le crash elle s'est préparée le 6
mai depuis le 6 mai 2012
oui donc justement les calques et n'a
fait que le lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle on électorale c'est érige
le chômage et rival françois hollande a
bien sûr les françois hollande a été
très clair il a dit si le chômage
continue à augmenter
je ne serai pas en mesure d'être
candidat je ne sais trop quoi dont acte
terminer on verra bien le moment venu
moi je pense que françois hollande doit
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en 2017
c'est celui qui peut rassembler la
gauche pour rassembler les français
pour être élu parce que l'offre
politique elle est simple les français
nous disent on ne veut pas revivre 2012
mais vraisemblablement il y aura marine
le pen nicolas sarkozy et françois
hollande
donc ils veulent pas le revivre enfin le
choix il devra libreville et le choix il
devra être là qu'on le veuille ou non
après on peut dire on peut voter pour
d'autres on verra bien mais on risque de
se retrouver avec ses 3 votre seul
argument c'est 2
de votre console à oisy le pen pourquoi
on dit ça et on a entendu dans le sujet
d'ailleurs monsieur harouna se dire le
suc argunas dire je vous dis on dira aux
français si vous mettez pop pour nous ça
maladroit il ya une chose qui est sûre
non mais vous avez entendu cet argument
et j'ai entendu alors qu'est ce que je
vais vous ne prenez pas votre je vais
vous répondre je ne reprends pas tout à
fait en compte mais je vais vous
répondre
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour les gens de
gauche c'est le front national nicolas
sarkozy ou françois hollande s'il y a
des gens je vais vous donner ma position
après s'il ya des gens de gauche puisque
vous parlez de cet argument oui et ils
disent nous ça ne nous intéresse pas bon
ben alors terminé on rentre à la maison
et puis on laissera à l'extrême droite
ça veut dire qu'on ait perdu tout
boussole est toujours pas illogique moi
ce que je pense c'est que les mesures
que nous avons prises les réformes que
nous avons fait et celles qui vont venir
encore peuvent permettre de relancer la
machine économique peuvent permettre de
faire de la redistribution et peuvent
permettre de faire la différence entre
une politique de droite une petite de
gauche parce que c'est bien de cela dont
il s'agit
quand nous allons arriver à l'élection
présidentielle si les choses se passent
comme je le souhaite
et bien il y aura des débats il y aura
des confrontations bilan contre milan
sondage projet contre projet là je
montre bien pourtant françois hollande
n'a pas la cote
aujourd'hui on se dire y compris chez
lise surtout chez les sympathisants pour
l'instant aujourd'hui à 50% des
électeurs de gauche qui souhaitent sa
candidature et 50 % qu'ils la souhaitent
pas bon ben on commence comme ça voilà
on est à 200 dans les deux ans qui
viennent nous allons faire ce travail
fera monter une stratégie de à aulas
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
l'objectif n'est pas de dire faut que
françois hollande soit élu pour être élu
pour être élu c'est pas nicolas sarkozy
qui tape soit à tous les matins en
disant je veux redevenir président de la
république lui il a une idée de la
france il a celle de la faire rayonner
enfin quand même quoi le 11 janvier et
ce qui s'est passé à bruxelles pour la
grèce quand j'ai entendu les trois
positions différentes en trois jours de
nicolas sarkozy je me dis
qu'heureusement heureusement que le chef
de l'état c'était françois hollande donc
l'un des arguments de campagne donc d'un
positionnement de françois hollande que
ça son idée de la france et bien sûr ça
son idée du
de l'europe et de la france elles sont
du côté gauche ribéry sera t-elle lagos
qu'elle est contestée à la gorge du
billet sera du ps non moi je pense que
la vieille gauche que la vieille
politique
je voulais déjà dit je crois ici c'est
terminé c'est terminé les vieux partis
qui entre font leurs trucs et puis on
est elle candidate c'est fini tout cela
les français n'en veulent plus
d'ailleurs quand je vais au bistrot ball
qui a fait ou l'apéro quand je rencontre
des amis quand je fais des dîners avec
des potes
qu'est ce qu'ils me disent mais mon
vieux tu a sacrément de morale de faire
de la politique parce que leur nous elle
nous fait germer voilà ce que j'entends
oui et donc à partir de là est belle
nous ramenons ces gens là avec françois
lambert une idée de la france
pas des polémiques stériles pas je suis
dans l'opposition donc je suis content
mais nécessaire même si c'est bien la
france une france qui rayonne dans le
monde
je crois qu'il l'a montré qu' un poids
fort au niveau européen la france ne
s'est pas ballotté
le couple franco-allemand madame merkel
monsieur hollande on a vu qu'ils avaient
d'eux qu'ils avaient de la pêche et de
la poigne ces derniers temps on a pas on
est pas allé là bas on voit bien la
stature de chef de l'état voilà
l'étranger voilà 77% de mais combien sur
itil du président le rhabille assurer
les gens sont surtout intéressés sur la
politique intérieure je vous dis
imaginez quand même moi je me place tous
les matins vers mes concitoyens mes
voisins dans la drôme à bourg de péage
dans la commune ceux qui sont au chômage
ceux qui ont peu de ceux qui ont peu de
revenus disney la politique qui est
menée ne va pas mais aujourd'hui c'est
fini on rasera gratis c'est fini la
politique en cinq jours
les gens ont entendu mon ennemi c'est la
finance et se disent donc du coup on va
prendre l'argent aux riches pour donner
aux pauvres
mais c'est pas aussi simple que ça nous
ce que nous pensons aussi qu'il faut que
l'économie redémarre que l'économie
fonctionne qui créent de l'emploi
c'est pas les socialistes ce sont les
chefs d'entreprise et les chefs
d'entreprise peuvent créer de l'emploi
par les mesures prises par le chef de
l'état et le gouvernement le pacte de
responsabilité cice il commence à porter
ses fruits
je le vois tous les jours dans mon
département pour les petites entreprises
et donc c'est sur la durée il reste
encore deux ans et j'espère est en
filtrant j'espère que nous arriverons à
avancer mais pour cela
il faudra aussi rassembler la gauche ah
oui voilà ce que françois hollande a une
base politique extrêmement étroite qui
survit à résister à gauche quand on voit
que vous ne la rassembler déjà pas pour
les régionales or pour les régionales
moi je vais vous dire soit la gauche est
unie sur la gauche est anéantie
elle va être à n'y a pas de géant
sérieux elle est désunie à date l'année
à deux tours dans une élection quand
même il ya deux tours dans une élection
moi j'appelle j'appelle mes amis
écologistes les communistes les partis
de gauche de le radier les radicaux et
cetera à se dire au moins dans deux
régions nord pas de calais picardie
immense île de ré et provence alpes côte
d'azur d'alliance attendait que l'on
gère depuis trois mandats ensemble que
l'on gère ensemble dont les uns et les
autres sont vice-présidents partagent le
même bilan font le même bon travail sur
les transports sur le sur l'aménagement
du territoire et caetera et pour des
raisons qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'élection régionale veulent partir de
façon indépendante
je pense que ce n'est pas responsable
mais moi je veux être unitaire pour deux
alors je leur dis si au premier tour
pour des raisons qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les régionales vous voulez vous
présenter assumons le fait d'ores et
déjà qu'il y aura un rassemblement de
ceux qui gouvernent en les régions
semblent pas comment nos concitoyens
dans la région rhône alpes où ailleurs
voit que la gauche gère la région mais
que aux prochaines élections régionales
ne serait pas ensemble ça n'a aucun sens
donc j'appelle à l'unité pour
rassemblement et il est encore temps
d'avancé et si ce n'est pas possible
pour le premier tour alors assumant
maintenant qu'au deuxième tour
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont géré
les régions ensemble doivent continuer à
le faire l'on peut avoir
on peut avoir des divergences sur la
politique gouvernementale menée sur la
poésie de la position du chef de l'état
ou du gouvernement
mais de quoi s'agit-il là l'élection
présidentielle sera après là c'est la
gestion ce gris région ce que vous
reproche justement rock écologie les
verts notamment c'est de dire
rassemblons nous derrière nous disons à
chaque élection c'est la même chose
si vous savez la politique sait les
rapports de force et la proportionnelle
on peut pas discuter quand un parti fait
20% un autre fait 10 c'est celui qui
fait 20% qui doit mener la liste après
lorsqu'il ya désaccord
il ya des accords de réciprocité enfin
pour les élections sénatoriales
les aînés sénateur europe ecologie les
verts qui ont été élus ils ont été élus
sur les listes socialistes aux élections
législatives de 2012
la plupart des députés qui ont été élus
n'auraient pas été élu s'il y avait eu
des candidats socialistes en face d'eux
donc c'est simple il faut bien
comprendre et pourquoi moi je milite
pour la social écologie pour le
rassemblement de toute la gauche car je
crois qu'il faut dépasser les appareils
il faut dépasser les trucs d'épicier de
boutiquiers il faut dépasser cela
quelle idée avant nous pour notre pays
pour la france la république l'écologie
le social l'économie on peut pas se
mettre d'accord bon sang de bonsoir là
dessus ben non bahmani la france est
difficile on a entendu marie noëlle il
va jusqu'au bout vous irez jusqu'au bout
et méritait aussi d'y arriver
bien sûr
l'idée d'une primaire là pour re
légitimer légitime et françois hollande
est ce que ça vous paraît une bonne idée
non mais qu'est ce que c'est une option
ça ne peut pas être une option enfin
lorsque un président de la république et
sortants s'il décide de se représenter
s'il est en situation si les principaux
responsables politiques autour de lui
veulent aller dans cette direction il
n'y a pas besoin de prières la primaire
avec une condition qu'elle connaît par
le bo a mis la gomme déposée par marie
noëlle lienemann et paul qui est arrivé
d'accord ce qui est posée parce qu'après
monsieur montebourg est vrai parce
qu'ils ont été en revenant lui il
aimerait être candidat qui recevait a
été en rupture avec ben qui ont été
servis par la république quand même
qu'ils ont été servis servi parce que
monsieur montebourg ils se sont servis
mais non monsieur montebourg et madame
filippetti ont été servis par la
république vous rendez compte soit
ministre de l'économie du redressement
productif de la culture mais quand on
est membre d'un gouvernement
on doit dépasser sa petite personne on
ne s'appartient plus mais c'est la
france quand on parle ont quitté ce
gouverneur est aujourd'hui il veut il
dire en livre savez chez moi on appelle
ça cracher dans la soupe
ma grand mère disait toujours faut avoir
la reconnaissance du ventre saga le mot
serviette ont bien travaillé bien choisi
alors quand le mot servi et donc bien
cheveux ils ont été choisis un moment
par le chef de l'état et ses retours
être membre d'un gouvernement
voilà donc aujourd'hui un peu de retenue
c'est ce que j'appelle ça il n'aura pas
la remplir on attend mon mur montebourg
évidemment avec monsieur dauphin qui
seront franchies
ministres virés de leur gouvernement
pour trouver d'autres mais vous nous
avez parlé de l'hypothèse nicolas
sarkozy pour vous et certaines
maintenant il ya aussi pour mm alain
juppé que bien passé d'après les
sondages et qui aurait d'ailleurs une
partie et les faveurs d'une partie de
l'électorat de gauche ce sera moi je
n'aime pas un spécialiste en ump en
stratégie des républicains oui il me
semble que les choses se passeront
dressant devant comme ça ça m'appartient
pas d'accord très bien parce que le
moment venu
les gens de gauche auront des faveurs
pour lequel vous êtes gauche parce qu'il
ya quand même une différence emprunter
la gauche quand on présentera le bilan
et le programme
merci katell merci guillaume merci à
vous la bonne était à vous invitons à
vous aussi et nous suivait prochain
rendez-vous de preuves par 3 sur public
sénat billet ce sera le 8 septembre de
très bonne et agréable semaine à vous
tous d'ici là a très vite